one year ago Democrats in the Senate
Judiciary Committee showed the world how
low they would go how dirty they would
play in order to derail the Supreme
Court nomination of Brett Kavanaugh well
of course despite their best efforts
Cavanaugh was confirmed
but now Radical Democrats and their
friends of the media are picking up
where they left off
the sexual misconduct allegations
against supreme justice Brett Kavanaugh
back in the spotlight a new book on
Kavanagh by two new york times
journalists mentions a previously
unreported claim they book detailing a
new allegation of sexual misconduct
against Cavanaugh it's serious questions
are being raised about the FBI
investigation into Supreme Court justice
Brett Kavanaugh were earlier
investigations mishandled this new
smashed and smear campaign involves
charges advanced might have heard about
it by these two New York Times reporters
in order to sell a book about the
Cavanaugh fight now the lewd accusations
they threw them out with no evidence or
even a victim they were quickly smacked
down by real journalists well that
should have ended this entire is
shameful saga but it didn't the authors
are defending their vile articles since
it's now become politically useful to
Democrats but their big bombshell is
imploding you see the Times editors
didn't want to include the victims name
so they admitted a key detail that
undermines the entire allegation this
supposed victim has no memory of this
ever happening didn't give an interview
well now the reporters excuses are
rolling in we had her name and you know
The Times doesn't usually include the
name of ricktum and so I think in this
case the editors felt like maybe it was
probably better to remove it did you
read it right before it went to print
you know I we thought we had they
thought they had a new story here also
well they were wrong but don't worry
about the slanderous charge of the
damage done you people are making too
much of this it's two paragraphs in a
you know almost 300 page book we did not
make a lot of this
world is making a lot of this that we
just put out every fact that we could
find that hadn't been reported
previously but the times reporters in an
excerpt used to hype their book omitted
this key fact what is it that Christine
blase Ford's friend Leland Kaiser now
doubts blase Ford's claim that Cavanaugh
ever sexually assaulted her and that's
not all Kaiser also told the authors she
felt pressured by Ford's friends
including a former FBI agent to change
her story otherwise though they had
publicize her past problems with drugs
and alcohol can you imagine this now
we've seen this type of smashing smear
job before when the deep state employed
similarly sleazy tactics and
uncorroborated allegations of course
against President Trump all the while
media lapdogs reporting it all without a
hint of skepticism and when it all
turned out to be hogwash
talking about the dossier etc the left
just moved on nothing to see here but
even after all the backtracking and the
Corrections Democrats are still using
this fake news for political gain in
Georgia calls her Cavanaugh to go are
now growing this morning at least six of
the Democratic presidential candidates
say Cavanaugh should be removed from the
bench what's become clear is that that
he should be impeached the house
absolutely has the ability to impeach
him I think that he has disqualified
himself for service on the Supreme Court
and he should step down or should be
impeached disqualified himself what is
he at 0% now predictably st. AOC has
returned her own verdict also calling
for Cavanaugh's impeachment and her
provocateur Protege congresswoman Ayana
Presley followed up with a resolution in
the House today which of course Kamala
Harris seemed almost take us her cue to
act Kamala is pursuing House Judiciary
Committee Chairman Jerry Nadler to
investigate and yes impeach Cavanaugh
now if they don't act a senator Harris
wants to turn it into the next molar
probe
the process by which he was confirmed
has created a crisis of confidence in
that court if the United States Congress
doesn't act well then let's let's
appoint it let's appoint an outside
counsel somebody who can who is neutral
who can review the evidence in this case
determine the credibility of the
witnesses we have to pursue justice here
that thud that's the sound of Kamala
falling off her high horse
okay first suing justice is the last
thing they're interested in that's
nearly impossible three decades after
any alleged wrongdoing especially one
with you know invisible victims and the
Democrats know it that's what's so sick
about all this
where Trump is on the campaign trail
selling peace and prosperity Democrats
are sowing chaos and calamity what
they're doing to Cavan are right now is
a classic leftist smear operation throw
out charges all over the top and Jeff
inject them into the media ecosystem
we're compliant journalists will eagerly
spread the fake news the charges are so
outrageous so lurid that they're beneath
response but the press possessed with
anti-trump hatred endlessly regurgitates
them over and over
hoping to inflict maximum damage and
remember they're doing all of this while
controlling only one house of congress
I'm here tonight to tell you imagine or
ask you imagine what they'll do if they
win the White House again give them the
presidency or the Senate and they'll use
the power of government to do to us what
they're doing to Brett Kavanaugh they'll
demonize opposing voices and work to
silence them or intimidate them but I
have to believe that fair-minded
Americans anyone who has a son or a
brother going off to college or is in
the workplace will see this new
Cavanaugh smear for what it is they said
revealing in
desperate commentary on the current
state of the Democrat Party and the
press that long ago stopped calling
balls and strikes and that's the angle